parti il faut que tu repartent avec moi
et donc reculer un peu la route est trop
court pour atteindre 80 du maïs à la
route là où on va on n'a pas besoin de
routes
la voiture volante à peupler
l'imaginaire des réalisateurs pendant
des décennies retour vers le futur
blade runner le cinquième élément
aujourd'hui elle fait carburer
l'imagination des constructeurs et ça
pullule sur youtube techniquement on
peut le faire depuis son laboratoire de
polytechnique le professeur soucier voit
émerger deux grands types de voitures
volantes celle qui ressemble à des
drones géant d'avoir tant qu'on parle de
multi coop terre ce que l'on peut
acheter qu'on éprouve un cocktail dans
n'importe quel magasin comme des jouets
les principes sont les mêmes
c'est le cas par exemple du ying un
projet chinois
l'un des pionniers du genre qui rêvent
de coloniser le ciel des grandes
métropoles mais ce qui donne des ailes
aux géants du secteur ce sont les
ambitions du ber d'ici les olympiques de
los angeles en 2028 l'entreprise pense
que son offre sera au point
commandez un déplacement aérien comme on
appellerait une voiture est embarqué
depuis le toit d'un immeuble pouvoir
décoller à la verticale ça veut dire
qu'on peut à peu près décollé de
n'importe où donc ça peut être au sein
d'une ville
pas besoin d'une piste de décollage
atterrissage donc avec une certaine
longueur à franchir et ensuite une fois
qu'on a effectué le décollage partir en
vol horizontal comme un avion qu est-ce
qui va compenser le poids d'appareils
maintenant c'est la portance créé par
l'ale et non plus la poussée créé par
les hélices
selon moi c'est le meilleur design pour
ce genre d'engin et c'est justement ce
véhicule que boeing vient de faire
décoller pour la première fois
un court vol stationnaire un an après le
test du modèle d'airbus
mais cette course entre les géants et
les autres va-t-elle vraiment aboutir à
quelque chose de nouveau
en fait fondamentalement pourquoi ce
serait différent de l'hélicoptère
aujourd'hui je pense qu'à un certain
nombre davantage que les drones sont
moins bruyants sont peut-être un petit
peu plus efficace a peut être de la
mobilité électrique donc il ya certains
avantages en termes de démission et de
pollution mais au delà je suis pas j'ai
du mal à voir les avantages
c'est sûr que ça nous ça me fait tous
rêver car dans la réalité un terminal de
ce genre pourrait bien créer un nouveau
noeud de congestion au lieu de l'éviter
pour vous un doc et marty mcfly pas tout
de suite à mon avis j'attends de mon
véhicule autonome d'abord ici mathieu
prost radio canada